dr. Warren Farrell has looked into this
subject quite closely he's the author of
the book the boy crisis and he joins us
tonight dr. ferral thanks a lot for
coming on so we know pretty conclusively
that men in America and in other
developed countries are falling behind
women in a lot of different measures to
what extent is fatherlessness driving
that do you think a great extent they're
falling behind women in all 63 leading
nations developed nations and in
developed nations there's the permission
for divorce that there isn't in non
development less developed nations and
also in developed nations there's the
permission for women to marry to have
children without being married and and
and that creates a huge division between
boys and a division of boys who are with
their fathers and quite well boys who
are not with their fathers do terribly
on more than 70 different measures of
measures like postpone gratification the
ability to be whether or not they're
depressed whether or not they're
drinking whether they're not there have
drugs the opioid crisis and even the
people who are involved as Isis recruits
all over the world there are almost
completely fatherless boys and the ones
that are girls are also follow this and
so everything you've been saying for the
series has been right on target with the
the importance of having children be
involved with both fathers mothers are
doing a huge amount of wonderful hard
work loving caring for their children
that's why they deserve that biological
father to be involved and when we tell
the biological father not only are you
important but the way that you father is
important the way that you would enforce
boundaries the way that you encourage
exploration the way that you could
encourage kids to get up and try again
the way that you encourage adventure and
mistaking the way that that we can play
together and create bonds these are the
things that mothers need to communicate
because when fathers are asked for and
valued they
back into the picture when they're not
they drop out so it doesn't sound like
anybody wins from fatherlessness so if
you know the trend is that fewer
families are forming more children are
growing up with that father's at home
nobody benefits from that at all why
aren't we sounding an alarm in this
society about that do you think we I
think we've put so much focus especially
in the Democratic Party on freedom for
women and freedom for women is a
wonderful thing I was in the board of
directors of the National Organization
for Women in New York City as you know
for many years and but freedom for women
stops when when they make the free
choice to have children and then the
then a different question has to emerge
which is what is best for the children
and what we see is evidence way beyond
what I ever expected before I started
doing the research for the boy crisis is
that that children do best when there is
not just a father not just a male role
model but the biological father
and therefore of biological father is
far less likely to drop out of the
process when there's marriage of 40
percent of even men and women who live
together who don't get married and have
children 40% of those fathers never see
their children after two years that's
those are numbers that will offend
people but that's what the science tells
us that it's obvious all anonymous I
appreciate that doctor thanks for coming
on and for that perspective it's it's
been a pleasure thank you